here is a Woman by well I assume she's a  woman she looks like a woman to me but  she might have a penis eye who knows  anymore her name is Jesse pocock  once again we are doing a trans segment  here and the expert her name is Jesse  pocock  in terms of parents rights to know at  schools I mean here in Colorado parents  don't have the right if a young person  is questioning their gender or their  sexuality there are laws in place that  say that they have the right to process  that with their trusted counselor and so  for our community the age of consent to  mental health therapy is 12 years old  that's just one more time her name is  Mrs Poca could have been mocock or less  [ __ ] that would have made more sense  she believes that we have people who are  protecting and supporting kids  um I could have sworn that was the job  of the parent